But here we go. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad, I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio,
the podcast. And today
[inaudible]
what's so interesting about the Cicada sounds is when you just hear it for the
first time, you just hear white noise just here,
just noise. But when you, um, learn what's going on,
you can hear the different parts of the orchestra.
That's David Rothenberg, composer and professor and writer.
And what he's going to do is he's going to take that huge wall of insect sounds
[inaudible] soon to be upon us, soon to be upon us and, and get really into it,
really start to dissect it.
But what he really loves to do really is he likes to play music with animals.
He goes around and finds individual animals or groups of animals to duet with.
And uh, if you don't mind you, I like to just go, just,
just introduce you to a few of his strange escapades or one of the first times
he tried this was with a, well that was a white crested, laughing thrush.
Oh right. Question. Laughing through.
Cause you know before I met the white crested, laughing thrush in Halo,
the way you're able to bring them up.
Cause if you ask an ordinary person like myself to say white crested,
laughing thrush, it's hard.
It should be much more well known because the white crested laughing.
Thrush is one of the best in the white crested laughing thrush shit thread.
Washington has them, Bronx through has them. They thrive very well in zoos.
But what they do is they sing duets, the males and females together.
So that's animals singing with animals. But here's what he did.
He went to the national aviary, which is in Pittsburgh.
First I stepped into the big tropical aviary where you wander and the birds run
or flying freely to big, warm kind of moist space.
He got there before the aviary opened, like 6:00 AM and they were,
when he walked into the case,
there were dozens of different kinds of birds flying around. And uh,
I was walking with my clarinet
playing up to the trees. Why is he doing this? Well he just wanted to see,
well that's him by the way. And he wanted to see what would happen.
And uh, as it turns out, nothing happened.
The bridge more or less ignored him. By then,
I was kind of kind of lost interests. Like nobody's paying attention to this.
It's a bad idea. And then all of a sudden
[inaudible]
hello the laughing thrush was interested.
That's the thrush
one little guy, brown feathers, dark beat.
At that moment,
anyone would say, hmm, I don't know, like doing and response. Yeah.
This is interesting. Something's happening here.
This bird and this clarinet is doing something together.
[inaudible] [inaudible] woo.
So as you're, as you're playing well,
what's going on in your mind at this point? I was just imagining,
I was sitting down with a musician who maybe couldn't talk to,
spoke another language besides English.
I couldn't talk to this musician, but I can make music together with them.
Okay. So that was his encounter with a thrush.
Let me take you on another little adventure just before we get to our big thing.
Uh, this is a diff, can I do this?
You have your attention for permission [inaudible] no, no, no. You can't. Oh,
all right. Well, I'm not going to ask you that. I'm just doing it good.
After a variety of bird duets in which I'm sure he frustrated many a thrush.
He then did a duet with an entirely different animal.
What the humpback whales,
the best thing about that story is nobody knew they sang until the 1960s so you
can try them but don't.
We'll spend most of their time except for the tops of them.
Underwaters the way we do be. Good point.
I was broadcasting my clarinet through an underwater speaker
listening with headphones to to what's coming out of an underwater microphone
and you here?
Yeah,
we just do from down there live clarinet and whale [inaudible]
this is so bizarre. What is the whale make of this?
I [inaudible] I don't speak whale.
Thinking about humpback whales is unlike most animals,
they change their songs from year to year. They're interested in new sounds,
so all the humpback whales in any one ocean are singing one song and then they
change it all together. No one knows why.
Why do they want to change their song if they all want to sound the same?
Well when you sound your song with the whale,
did the whale react like the thrush? I think it's different,
but I would say the whale seem to change what he was doing.
Now it can be a little hard to hear exactly what David's talking about.
It took me a few listens to pick out the distinguishing moment,
but here's what the whale was doing. When David showed up
[inaudible]
it was doing this thing. We would go, Whoa, and then down and woo and then down
over and over. And here's what it started doing.
A few minutes after he'd been playing the clarinet.
[inaudible]
the whale kind of extends the note. Whales tend to go
[inaudible] and clarinets tend to go, Ooh, they play a steady tone.
And so the way I was trying to play a more steady note
[inaudible]
maybe,
no, I, I don't know that you just a little bit of an extended line. It's
[inaudible]. I mean, it's awesome. No, I don't get, I love listening to this,
but I don't, I mean, I don't, it just sounds like
the whales still doing well. Well,
David says that when he played the recording to some of the two whale scientists
and they all are shocked, all, uh, every,
every scientist I played that to was,
did not believe that what I played them was actually alive recording.
They thought I'd done something to it, which I didn't. I mean, they,
they never heard a whale make a sound like that. I'm assuming,
which implies that the whale was reacting to his clarinet. Well,
because maybe the way I was just saying,
shut up. Shut up up there.
Well, however you want to resolve it. Like we, we, we, uh,
we should move on to the real purpose of our,
of our gathering here this afternoon or, okay, whatever.
Every time you're listening to this 2:00 AM,
which is that he then turned to this sound right here.
Yep. Play. This is the sound of lots of Cicadas.
And, and when you, and I hear it, I mean,
it just sounds like an enormous block of monotone. No noise.
Yes sir. Just screech, you know, elaborate screech I knowing. But David says,
actually, if you know what's going on in here, if you learn to dissect it, wow.
Pretty soon you can pick out up to nine separate sounds made by the three
unrelated species Cicada that are there at the same time. Can you,
can you walk us through the nine different sounds? At least some of them.
By the way, that was our producer Lynn Levy. Okay.
We have three basic species that come out whenever there's an emergence,
they're all there. So now I didn't, you know, realize that this we're doing,
you're walking through the woods and you hear this enormous white noise,
which you're actually hearing are three different kinds of Cicada,
three different species singing,
three very different songs that are all mixed together.
So you can't tell them apart. And then each one of those songs,
each of those three has three parts, which is how you get to the number nine.
Any case here are the three species. This is number one. Magid,
CICADA Kassin I makes the white noise sound
sure. Sure.
And they, they, they, they swell together. They synchronize. So they'll all go
and then they fly around a bit. Do that now. Jump up up. Yup.
Go up your feet and you get back into to do it again.
There you go. Okay, so that species number one,
how here is species number two magister Qaeda stepped in.
[inaudible] is making like
[inaudible].
It's kind of irregular.
[inaudible]
so that's the bebop style kind of. Yeah. And there's fewer of those than there.
Quieter. So less is known about them. Can I hear that one again?
Shall we got the white noise one? The bebop one. Now here's number three.
Magic CICADA Sept and [inaudible] the most popular and known sound.
And that's going fear. The Pharaoh sound fear rope.
Wow. The [inaudible].
And the thing is, when you actually hear millions of them,
all you hear is [inaudible].
[inaudible].
If you take one and multiply hundreds and thousands of time, tail disappears.
You just hear this tone. I mean, this is what we hear,
but what would the a Cicada hear in all this? Oh, well this is the whole story.
Well, see,
the thing about Cicadas is that this Acadias who sing here are the males,
just the guys, and they sing a four. It's the amazing song really. You know,
there are lots of songs you saying this is a, it's one of those kinds.
And the idea being the females here, all this sound. Yeah.
They find the males
like the grand mess of music,
like a disco or it's called the Lek by biologists,
which pretty much means disco anyway. Yeah.
And then you were a guy looking for a date.
You might not join with lots of other guys,
but these animals join together for what purpose? So the females can find them.
But if you've got like a, a billion cicadas crowded into a disco,
then how do you,
how does a single male and a single female a notice each other?
They don't have to, they just bumping into each other and then it's on,
you know, 17 years ago,
John Cooley and David Marshall discovered things were more complicated than
that.
They discovered the females make a sound after the male finishes his sound.
So say you're one of these males, go ahead.
Uh hmm.
And the female has to make a wing flick. This tiny little flick.
Exactly.
One third of a second after the male stops or do so it's like
[inaudible]
nobody imagined such a thing was going on and they didn't imagine insects or
doing anything that's called [inaudible].
Well for one thing it sounds like that would be a male to female bit of business
one to one. When you listened to all these animals,
you don't think they ever have a one them. They are like so many of them,
millions of a males are making the pharaoh sound. But when you're close to one,
you know the female, here's fear. Oh, if there's one close enough,
she makes the wing flick and the male knows to approach her a little bit and he
stopped and he goes on with a second sound.
It's called by John Cooley court to court to his like,
oh, uh, no pharaoh, Pharaoh.
And then she makes the wings like again, same one as far as we know. Okay.
Where does that tell Mr Mr, I love you guys.
Time to start meeting and make the third sound.
Just more like that, that, that, that, that, that,
let's do that again. So you use your hello is [inaudible]. Yeah,
I'm getting closer is
what's her offer
now we're kissing and et Cetera, et cetera. Is
that, that's what's up that, that, that, that, that,
so now you know when the cicadas coming,
you hear this massive war.
What you're really hearing is an orchestra of sex. This,
just think of all these little animals getting ready to do what they were born
to do,
what they've been waiting 17 long years in the ground to do and all the while
it's the songs that matter. They're like following these little rules,
simple rules that together it shows how very simple organisms can create things
of great complexity and beauty.
Each individual doesn't have to know that much about the whole and still
interesting things happen, which,
which gives you a different view of human life.
Your one little part in this giant thing. You,
you don't have to really know what's happening,
but you're doing your little bit for it for the whole of creation or evolution
or life for music.
Can you do your own little thing and you're [inaudible] sure where it leads,
but for the individual Cicada for Tommy Cicada or Betty Cicada,
it's all pretty simple. They have their sex, they lay eggs on twigs of trees,
the eggs hatch, and then tiny little larvae,
cicadas will fall to the ground and the Milton burrow into the warm earth and
attach themselves to the roots of trees and then start sucking the fluid from
tree roots. And they will do this for years and years and years.
It's a slowly growing and then for some reason that nobody can quite fathom at
the exact same moment. It's body time.
There are different broods of them.
So different years you can go somewhere in the country and maybe there's some
coming out.
And why is it that the one that's about to come out here in the northeast,
why does that happen? Only every 17 years.
Why 17 the honest answer is we really don't know.
We do have some evidence of how they keep track of the years,
which is at the CICADA monitors the temperature. We don't know how,
but that's what they pay attention to. So in the ground,
they're not just eating tree juice.
They're also going to have a little thermometer somehow they're paying it.
They have a little counting thermometer. They count the number of years.
Then they know when to come out. A few years ago in my parents' house,
I did see one in the wrong year and every year a few of them wake up.
Where's the party? Oh really? You Have Rip Van Winkle One? Yeah.
They don't always count correctly. You know who's really bad?
Must be a lonely experience. Yeah.
The lonely Cicada looking for its kind the wrong year. The wrong place.
Can they go back down and go back to that? It? I don't think up.
They've changed. They come from their larval stage and the wings have come out.
They can't crawl back and lose the wings. Oh, did it sing?
That loan's a Canaan. Ah, yeah. Hey was thinking
to no one to no one. To me.
You can kind of
imagine David picking up his clarinet.
Um,
and joining in
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thanks to John Cooley and to David Marshall.
And now Jed wants to say something.
What do I want to say about Glen Levy's favorite song?
If you go to yes, and if you go to radio lab.org,
you can download a, uh, a song from David Rothenberg's, uh,
album chosen by our producer, Lynn alleviate is her favorite song.
You can download it for free. Also,
David Rothenberg has a new book out called Bug Music.
And if you happen to be on the east coast, we have,
well you can do this from any coast you like,
but we have a map where you can track where these little critters are popping
up, which there I'm doing right now. Yeah, just,
just barely in Georgia and the Carolinas and not in Brooklyn yet, but soon
[inaudible]
that'd be frying them up,
making some Tim knower out making cause Rocco's cause the little guy will come
up to you and go, I could get to cut that bit. Got to cut the cut on your leg.
He'll show up to the ground and burrow into the earth, and we won't see you for,
I don't know. It'll be like either 13 or 17 years. Thanks for listening.
I'm Jack. I boom. Rod. I'm Robert Krulwich. See you.
[inaudible]
this is Willie from North Carolina.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org.
Okay. Uh,
no.